[Müzik]
hepiniz hoş geldiniz Herkese merhabalar
diliyorum enerji Madem yükseldi müzikle
beraber aynı şekilde devam etme
tarafındayım Umarım benim sunum
bittikten sonra da aynı enerjiye sahip
oluruz küçüklüğüm ve Gençliğim
Kayseri'de geçti
ergenliğimin ilk yılları çok enerjik bir
durumdaydı Çünkü ben 80'leri gördüm
1980'lerde çocuk olanlar varsa
hatırlayacaktır o zaman etrafımızda
Yakar topu oynamak işte çanak çömlek
oynamak ağaca tırmanmak gibi farklı
aktivitelerimiz vardı Yaşadığımız evin
hemen önünde yaz kış yeşilliğin hiçbir
zaman kaybolmadığı çam ağaçları ile dolu
devasa bir fark vardı 4-5 yaşlarındaki
halimi Hatırlıyorum da o Park benim için
inanılmaz büyüktü ve parkın sonuna kadar
gitmek korkutucu geliyordu Hatta ilk kez
10 yaşında parkın bir ucundan diğer
ucuna tek başıma gelebildiğinde kendini
son derece büyük ve cesur bir Resul
olarak görmüştüm ama şu an bakıyorum da
parkın eni 60 metre boyu 600 ila 700
metre civarında Aslında Ortalama bir
farkmış ama 4-5 yaşındaki bir
çocukluğunu düşünürsek devasa orman gibi
bir şey
sanırım 2014 yılıydı annemiz ziyarete
gittiğimde bu parka bakan balkonda
Oturup muhabbet ediyorduk muhabbet
sırasında ona bu farktan bahsetti Ya ben
küçüklüğünde Aslında birazcık Korkardım
dedim parkın sonuna kadar gitmiyor
giderken başıma bir şey gelecek diye
zaman zaman Tedirgin olurdum filan dedim
Laf lafı açtı çay muhabbeti ile beraber
giderken bana çok fazla Hatırlamadım ama
Hayal mi Yani aklımda olan bir aradan
bahsetti Benim küçüklüğümle ilgili
Sanırım 6-7 yaşlarındaymışım şimdi
annemin ağzından size olayları bir gün
Evde ev işleri yaparken kapı zili çaldı
ama durmadan çalıyor Eski Zilleri bilen
bilir elinizde olduğu müddetçe susmayan
ve kulak rahatsız eden bir zil sesi
Vardır dedim önemli bir şey herhalde
hemen gittim kapıyı açtım Kapıyı
açtıktan sonra baktım karşımda karşı
komşu dedi ki Emine Mehmet elinde
bıçakla parkta bir şey yapıyor o an
panik halinde Acaba nedir ne değildir
diye hemen ayakkabı mı giyip arkada
duruyor
aklımda gelen en temel sorulardan birisi
şu; Mehmet bıçağı Nereden buldu ikincisi
kocaman bana Fark ettirmeden nasıl
götürdü Bu soruların cevaplarından erken
parkta seni gördüm uzaktan görünce
baktım elindeki küçük meyve bıçağı ilk
bir rahatladım diyor çünkü baban sizin
meyve bıçaklarınız uzun köreltmişti ki
kendinizi ya da meyve keserken zarar
görmeyeli diye ilk bir rahatladım yanına
girene kadar yanına geldim Ve baktım ki
önünde bir kuş var o an Tedirgin oldum
oğlum kuşa ne yaptın dedim Sen Gayet net
bir şekilde elindeki bıçağı gösterip
kuşu göstererek anne bunun için açmam
lazım dedi Ben neden dedim Anne bu kuşu
yerde buldum Bunun içi bozulmuş bunu
tamir edeceğim diğerleri gibi uçacak
dedim sanırım bilinmezliğine dair en net
hatırladığım anı benim bu olsa gerek
baktığımız zaman insan Aslında her
durumda bilinmezlikle beraber yaşıyor
garip bir canlı olduğumuzu söylemek
mümkün insanın Çünkü insan dediğimiz
kavram sürekli bilinmesi bilir hale
getirmeye çalışıyor ve kafasında her
zaman bu bilinmezliklerle beraber oluyor
Neden sorusunun cevabını arıyoruz
canlılar dünyasına baktığımız zaman
insan kadar Neden sorusunu algılayan ya
da neden sorusu üzerine çalışan bir
varlık yok Yalnızca Biz zihnimizdeki
yerlerin Neden sorusunun cevabını bulmak
için çabalarız ve etrafınızdaki
insanlara Neden sorusunu sorup bilinmez
ortadan kaldırmaya çalışırız Hatta bu
Bazen o kadar abartıp duruma geçerken
bizi ilgilendirmese dahi herhangi bir
kaza olduğunda elimizde çekirdeğimizi
alıp acaba orada ne oluyor Geçit diyerek
bir kaza yerine bakabilecek kadar da
rahat değilsinizdir Çevremizdeki
insanlarla baktığımızda işte burada kim
vardır meteorologlar bilim insanları
işte kimyagerler Psikologlar gibi birçok
bilim insanlarının yaptığı çok temel bir
şey var
akıllarındaki Neden sorusunun cevabını
bulmak Yani bir bilinmesi bilinir hale
getirmek Nitekim 2018'de kaybettiğimiz
ve kara delikler konusunda çığır açan
düşüncelerin sahibi ünlü fizikçi ve
kozmonoksiven Hawking'in the
her şeyin teorisi isimli çalışmasında da
var olan evrendeki bilinmezleri çözmek
ve bunu bize sunma tarafında yaptığı
çalışmalar vardı
bilinmezlik kavramına baktığımız zaman
Hayatımızın her anında bilinmezlik ve
içeceğiz Hiçbir zaman bilinmezliği
ortadan kaldırmak gibi bir durum söz
konusu değil ama biz sürekli
kaldırabilecek gibi bir düşüncemiz var
Kendi içerimizde örnek veriyorum eski
zaman dilimlerine baktığımız zaman daha
bilim bu kadar gelişmemişken şu an
Çevrenizde gördüğünüz ahşap Metal
Plastik Her ne olursa olsun onların çok
ortak bir temel maddeden geldiğini
düşünüyorum ama sonrasında anlaşıldı ki
bilim insanları çalışan insanlar aslında
ortak bir madde olmadığını atom diye bir
madde olduğunu keşfettiler ama
bakıldıktan sonra birbirinden farklı
atomlar verdi bu defa atomları farklı
kılan ne yeni bilinmez çıktı elektron
Proton çekirdeği gibidir Tamam Bunlar
çok güzel ama Peki daha farklılaştıran
neler olabilir atom altı parçacıklara
kadar gitti bu olay gördüğüm üzere
aslında bir bilinmesi bildiğimiz zaman
başka bir bilinmezle karşılaşıyoruz her
şeyi bilmek gibi bir ihtimal söz konusu
değil Yine örnek veriyorum bilim
dünyasındaki gelişmelerle beraber çok
ciddi şekilde diyenler
baktığımız zaman insanda meme kanseri
olup olamayacağıyla alakalı birçok data
yerdir diyoruz ve bu nedenle bazı riskli
kişilere sizde meme kanseri olma riski
çok yüksek tip onlara uyarı
gönderilebiliyor Nitekim Amerika'da
bununla alakalı çok ciddi şekilde
çalışmalar yapılıyor meme kanseri
riskini biliyoruz ama kişinin ne zaman
meme kanseri olacağını bilmiyoruz
veyahut da meme kanseri ile alakalı
gerçekten de %100 karşılaşıp
karşılaşmayacağını bilmiyoruz Yine yakın
zamanda Hala da etkisini gördüğümüz 19
Vakası dünyada periyodik bir şekilde bir
pandemi riski olduğunu biliyoruz bilim
insanları bunu sürekli söylüyor çok
sıklıkla tekrar eden bir durum ama bir
sonraki pandeminin karşımıza ne zaman
çıkacağını bilmiyoruz ne kadar insan
etkileyecek bilmiyoruz kaç insanı
öldürecek bilmiyoruz bunun gibi hiçbir
şey aslında bilinmez Biz sürekli olarak
bilmeye çalışıyoruz ve her şey
bilebildikçe kendimizi rahat ettirecek
veya Hatta bir şeyleri bildiğiniz zaman
hayatı daha iyi kurgulayacağımız gibi
sahte bir illüzyona sahibiz Şemsi
Tebrizi Yeter ki biz bilinmeyende yaşar
ve hareket ederiz bilinen geçmiştir
Peki bilim dünyasında ne oluyor ya da
bilimsel makalelerde bilinmezlikle
alakalı neler var Buna bakacak olursak
İlk olarak şunu çok net bir şekilde
söyleyebiliriz İnsan zihni bilinmezi
sürekli biner hale getirmeye çalışıyor
Peki bilinmezler arasındaki farklılıklar
neler yahutta her birimiz aynı birimize
aynı tepkiyi veriyoruz Tabii ki de hayır
insan gerek kendi gerek çevresindeki
olaylarla beraber Bilinmeze karşı bir
tolerans geliştiriyor bu tören artık
belirli bir ışık seviyesine gelene kadar
hiç sıkıntı yok güvenli bölgede kalıyor
problem yaşamıyor ama eşik seviyesi
geçtikten sonra bir anda tehdit dalgası
oluşmaya başlıyor tehdit algıladığımız
zaman insanlar ve hayvanların ortak bir
özelliği var hem fizyolojik hem de
psikolojik olarak 3 temel davranışımız
var bizim nedir kaç doğum savaş
ilk olarak sinyal ediliyor amigdra
sinyal gönderiyor Eğer kaç ya da savaş
tepkisini göstereceksek sempatik sinir
sistemi üzerinden adrina sistem
üzerinden sinir sistemine geçiyor Eğer
don kısmı varsa o da paycell'den hareket
ediyor don kısmında yine bir başka
bilinmez karşımıza çıkıyor insan ya da
Candan Neden don tepki veriyor bunun bir
iki açıklaması var Birincisi Eğer
karşınızda bir an varsa bize zarar
verecek bir durum varsa öyle bir durumda
onun radarına girmemek adına tepkisiz
kalıyoruz İkincisi ise o an için Ne
yapacağımızı bilmiyoruz bir başka bir
bilinmez çıkıyor karşımıza
akademik makaleler yeniden dönecek
olursak yine yapılan çalışmalardan
kişinin bilinmezse karşı toleransı
düştükçe tehlike algısının arttığı
yönünde bunu bir parçası da Tahterevalli
örneğinde anlatabiliriz bilinmezlik
federansımız ya da
bilinmezek toleransı arttıkça tehlikemiz
azalıyor O yüzden yapılan çalışmalar
Mesela şunu gösteriyor bilinmezlik düşük
olan bireylerdeki Amerikalı aktivasyonu
çok daha yoğun aynı zamanda bu kişiler
akranlarına göre öz yeterliliklerin çok
daha düşük olduğu görülmüş ve yine
bilinmedik düşük olan insanlardaki
herhangi bir bilinçsize karşı göstermiş
olduğu tepki direkt tehlikesi olduğu
yönde
tam tersini düşünürsek Bilinmeze karşı
yüksek olduğunda ne oluyor işte böyle
bir durumda rahatlıyoruz grafikte
Görüldüğü üzere güvenli alanımızı çok
daha arttırmış oluyoruz böyle bir
durumda ve bulunduğumuz çevredeki
tehlike arkası minimize etmiş oluyoruz
tehlike var mı öncekiler belki aynı ama
kendinizi bu şekilde motive etmeyi daha
çok seviyoruz
Bu nedenle dikkat ederseniz iş yerinde
uyanık kaldığım zaman da bakarsak
evindekinden çok daha fazla odada Zaman
geçiriyoruz ama iş yerini rahatınız
eğilimi evde rahatız veya tatillerde 5
yıldızlı otellere gidiyoruz gittikten
sonra otellerdeki konforlar evden çok
daha iyi olabiliyor oradaki yemek içmek
temizlik gibi birçok şeyin derdi yok
evde bunlar var ama otellerde ya da
tatil merkezlerinde Bunlar yok Ama ona
rağmen herkesten duygunuz ortak bir şey
var evde çok daha rahatım Neden peki
Çünkü bilinmezlik kavramı bulduğumuz
evde çok daha az bir mekandaki
bilinmezlik sayısını ne kadar düşükse
bizim rahatımız o kadar fazla oluyor
bu durumda baktığımız zaman biz
bilinmezliği neden tehlike olarak
algılıyoruz bununla alakalı evrimsel
psikoloji ve bilimsel çalışmaların bize
anlattığı şey şu;
insanla bildiğiniz gibi bir ara Avcı
dönemdeydik o döneme gittiğimiz zaman
etrafımıza baktığımız zaman göreceğimiz
şeylerden birisi bu Avcı toplayıcı
dönemde Vahşi bir Doğa var vahşi doğada
şu anki gibi korunaklı sitelerimiz yok
şu anki gibi korunaklı evlerimiz de yok
veya bizim güvenliğimizi sağlayacak
polis asker Şövalye gibi bir durumumuz
da yok Acıktık ne yapacağız şu anki gibi
gidebileceğiz bir restoran da yok ya da
bir lokantada yok yapılabilecek şey çok
basit dışarı çıkıp havalanmak bugün dahi
Hindistan'da leoparların vahşi doğadan
gelip insanların yaşam yerlerinde onlara
saldırdı ve zarar verdiklerini biliyoruz
işte böyle bir durumda
ne diye soracak olursanız insan
doğduktan sonra 2 ila ortalama 3 yıl
diyebiliriz bu dönemdeki yaşadığımız
herhangi bir şey hatırlamıyoruz şimdi
biz buna bebekteki analiz kavramı
diyoruz
bebeklik hamlesi yaşamadığımızı ifade
doğduk doğmamızla beraber Her birimizin
gözüne bir gözlük takıldığını düşünün ve
hayatı O saatten sonra bu gözlükle
beraber tanıyor ve tanımlıyoruz Mesela
bizim gözlük çıbımız sarı olsun sarı
gözlükle beraber Dünyaya bakıyoruz sarı
gözlükle beraber insanlara bir şekilde
tanımlayıp tüm çevremizdeki her şeyi
Buna göre tanımladığımızı düşünün
delmeye bakıyoruz sarı elma süper harika
işte elma kırmızıya döndüğü zaman süper
doğaya bakıyoruz her şey olması
gerektiği gibi Renkler çok iyi mavi renk
yeşil renk nasıl öğrenmişsek o şekilde
renk skalası var sonrasında eğitimimize
devam ediyoruz ilkokul ortaokul lise
derken süper film birinde birisi geliyor
ve omuzumuza dokunuyor diyor ki aslında
senin gördüğün renkler sana doğru gelse
doğru değil zihniniz karışıyor bir parça
Acaba ne demek istiyor diyorsunuz daha
sonra o size şundan bahsediyor Sen
doğumla beraber herkesin gözüne bir
gözlük takılıyor ve senin gözlüğünde
Aslında sarı renkli Bu yüzden senin mavi
bildiğin şey aslında mavi Ama senin
bildiğin mavi o mavi
kulak oluyorsunuz Acaba gerçek mi
yapıyorsunuz
aranızda Truman Show filmi izleyenler
varsa hatırlayacaktır
zaman zaman oradaki oyunculardan
bazıları gelip ona yaşadığı hayatın
sahte ve kurgu olduğunu söylüyor anlam
veremediği bir durum oluyordu aynen bu
şekilde bir durumla karşılaştığını
düşünüyorum
kişi size Aslında insanların 9 farklı
filtreden birisiyle bu hayatta geldiğini
ve tüm hayatını bununla beraber
geçirdiğini söylüyor örnek veriyorum
sizin sarıydı Siz bu nedenle tüm
Hayattaki her şeyi sarı filtreleri veya
bir başkasınınki mavi o benzer şekilde
mavi bu hayatta tanıyor ve Tanınmıyor
Bu saatten sonra bakıyorsunuz ki aslında
Hayat yaşadığınız birçok çatışma bu
kişilik yapılarından yarattığı bu
renklerden kaynaklı sıkıntıymış Aslında
Siz size göre sarı gelen şey Neyse bunu
savunuyorsunuz ama karşıdakinin mavi
filtrelere bakıyorsa ona bakıp ona göre
sıvıyor ve kardeşinizle kendiniz
arasındaki farkı bile böyle anlıyorsunuz
Hatta tek yumurta ikizleri neredeyse
yeni tip olarak %100 aynı olmasına
rağmen bu kişilerin yaşam şekli
birbirinden daha farklı oluyor
bilinmezler karşılaşıldığında daha
farklı oluyor o saatten sonra bunlar çok
daha anlıyor ve anlamları biliyorsunuz
İşte ben böyle bir olayı 2008 yılında
ilk kez sistemi tanıdıktan sonra yaşadım
Az önceki bahsettiğim metafor'daki 9
farklı renk ya da 9 farklı filtre olduğu
gibi insanların dokuz farklı kişilik
yapısını doldurur herhalde bu yapıyı
öğrendikten sonra Aslında her yapının da
benzer şekilde kendine dair bu hayatta
var olan bir filtresi olduğunu gördüm Bu
yüzden kişi birbiriyle arkadaşları ile
kardeşi farklı bir bakış açısı olduğunu
gördükten sonra tüm hayatını yeniden
almak zorunda kaldım Çünkü benim Doğru
bildiğim şey aslında Bana göre doğru
olduğunu öğrendim Örneğin İlk girişte
anlattığım olayda birçok arkadaşım ölü
kuşu gördüğü zaman geçip gidiyor Hiç
umursamıyordu Belki de bazen tiksinip
uzak duruyordu ama benim yapıp onu bir
şekilde Çalışıcı hale getirmeye
çalışıyordu çünkü ben Neden sorusunun
cevabını hep bilimsel yollarla Yani bir
insandı hayatı boyunca bu şekilde
geçirdim bilim benim için en büyük Gizem
çözücüydü ve en büyük mutluluk
kaynağıydı sonrasında fark ettiğim ki
bilim sadece benim kişilik yapımındaki
insanlar için bu kadar önemli bir
mutluluk kaynağı başkası için değil
ve bilimde Bende çok büyük açılımlar
yaptı Instagram öğrenmekle beraber
attığı tohum elegram sisteminin bilimsel
taraftaki çalışmalarımı birazcık daha
kişilik tarafına gönderdi moleküler
alanda yaptığım çalışmalar moleküler
Mühendislik alanında yaptığım çalışmalar
daha çok kişilik kuramı ya da
ne içi gibi dergilerde yayın yapmış
olmama rağmen bugüne kadar cüzdan fazla
uluslararası konferanslarda bildiri
sunmuş olmama rağmen hırkı yakın
makarayı almış olmama rağmen doktora
sonrasında ben lisansla yeniden sınava
girip tekrardan psikoloji bölümüne
okudum ve bunların hepsinden sonra fark
ettiğim şey şu ki insan ilk olarak
kendini bilmedi
ilk olarak yapmanız gereken şey kendi
bilinmezlerimizi ortadan kaldırmalıyız
başka bir şey değil Ancak bunu yaptıkça
sizin de diğer arasındaki kahramanca ya
da oradaki kirada çıkan sorunlar ortadan
kaldırabiliyorsunuz
Peki ben kişilik yapım öğrendim diyelim
Bu yeterliyim tabi yeterli değil Çünkü
bu şunu sağlıyor bize eğer biz sarı
çerçevede sarı gözlükle bakıyorsak
dünyaya Her şey bu sarı haliyle
görebiliyoruz ama bunun dışında Biz sarı
gördüğümüzü fark ettikten sonra bir
başka Seher kırmızı bir şekilde
görüyorsa bizim için harekete çatışmaya
çok fazla aslında değiştirmiyor yine biz
doğru görebiliyoruz Ama onun kıyımızdan
gördüğünü de görmemiz gerekiyor Bu
yüzden sadece kendi içtik yanımızı
çözmemiz yetmiyor aynı zamanda
etrafımızdaki diğer insanlarla yapılan
görüp onların yapılarını anlayıp onların
filtrelerinde gördükten sonra hakikaten
gerçekten empati kavramını Ortaya
çıkartmış olabiliyoruz Şimdi ben size
soruyorum eğer kendi kişilik yapınız ile
alakalı olan durumlara ya da kendi küçük
yapınızdaki özellikleri 10 yaşında fark
etmiş olsaydınız şu an hayatınızda neler
değişirdi
teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]
[Müzik]